Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Two, Episode Six, Part Two.
Fourth, interest organisations and associations.
In Denmark, there is a tradition that politicians involve associations and interest organisations in political decisions.
The relevant organisations are heard and try to make their views known to the ministries, for example by writing or coming to meetings, when new legislation that affects their interests and members is being worked on.
They can also, by agreement, show up at the Folketing's various committees.
Interest organisations in that way seek to gain influence and to influence the political agenda.
But they also often contribute useful knowledge to the political process.
Interest organisations are often part of committees and working groups set up by the government.
Interest organisations arose at the same time as the political parties, at the end of the 1800s.
They continue to play an active role in political life.
In the beginning there were employers' associations, trade unions and farmers' associations.
While the parties took care of the political fight, the interest organisations focused more narrowly on their members' interests, including their economic conditions and working conditions.
In this period and well into the 1900s, there were close ties between parties and interest organisations.
The Social Democrats cooperated closely with the Danish Confederation of Trade Unions, LO, the largest main organisation for trade unions in Denmark, which is now called the Danish Trade Union Confederation, FH.
The Conservative People's Party cooperated with the Danish Employers' Confederation, DA, which is the organisation of the employers, while LO, now FH, is the main organisation for the trade unions.
And Venstre with the Agricultural Council, Landbrugsrådet, which is now called Landbrug og Fødevarer, Agriculture and Food.
Through the last roughly 25 years, the close ties between parties and organisations have become looser.
All interest organisations seek to influence most of the parties in the Folketing.
Many new interest organisations have also come along.
Today, interest organisations and associations cover nearly all areas of political life.
The old organisations have been supplemented by a number of new ones within areas such as climate, health and education.
Fifth, the media and the public debate.
The media play an important role for democracy in Denmark in several ways.
On the one hand, radio, TV, newspapers, magazines and social media and so on help bring the political debate out to a wider circle of citizens.
On the other hand, the media also function as channels where citizens can contribute to the debate with their opinions.
Finally, the media can themselves influence the political agenda.
In all three ways they act as a link between politicians and voters.
The Danish media are independent of the government.
They can therefore freely debate and take a critical view of the political agenda.
Earlier, a number of Danish newspapers functioned as mouthpieces for the political parties.
They were, in other words, controlled by party politics.
Even in many smaller towns, four newspapers were published, which represented the four old parties: the Social Democrats, Venstre, the Social Liberal Party and the Conservative People's Party.
The newspapers faithfully reproduced the party's views, and the readers were often members of the party.
During the 1960s, newspapers changed character and freed themselves from the political parties.
Most newspapers do still have political views, which can be centre-right or left-leaning.
But these views are mainly expressed in the newspapers' so-called editorials, which are the newspapers' own comments on political events.
Since the 1980s, newspapers have taken on the task of being "society's watchdog" even more clearly.
That is, they keep an eye on all kinds of holders of power on behalf of citizens.
On most media, a story that is critical of those in power is regarded as a good news story.
That is why people also talk about the media as "the fourth power of the state".
In the last approximately 15 years, the political debate has increasingly moved to social media such as Facebook, X, formerly Twitter, TikTok and Instagram.
Here the politicians can themselves present or comment on a case instead of appearing for an interview with journalists in newspapers, on radio or on TV.
The population can likewise comment themselves, ask questions, write or share a post about political topics.
On the one hand, the emergence of social media has given citizens easier and more direct access to communicate with each other and with the politicians.
On the other hand, debate on social media often takes place without the journalists having the opportunity to ask critical questions.
That can contribute to weakening the media's opportunity to be "society's watchdog".
Now let's bring democracy home: democracy in everyday life, citizenship.
Democracy has spread to many parts of Danish society.
For example, there is a tradition that citizens can help set the framework for their everyday lives.
For example in the local school, where parents and pupils can discuss the school's affairs in the school board, or in class councils and pupil councils.
This democracy in everyday life is also found on the boards of housing associations and cooperative associations.
There is also a long tradition of employees having insight into, and influence on, conditions at their workplace through a so-called cooperation committee, a samarbejdsudvalg.
In all of these contexts, people work according to democratic principles.
Denmark is also characterised by a rich associational and organisational life.
There are not many other countries where people are members of as many associations and organisations.
About 90 percent of the Danish population are members of at least one association, and about 35 percent have done voluntary work through an association.
On average, every Dane is a member of three to four associations or organisations.
They can be organisations on the labour market, or leisure organisations where the members gather around a common hobby or interest such as football, scouting, birdlife, chess or ceramics.
Others are members of organisations that want to promote particular causes, for example protecting the environment, like the Danish Society for Nature Conservation.
For many citizens, association life and everyday democracy also work as a training in democracy.
Here you discuss matters with each other, gather knowledge, test arguments, make compromises and vote on proposals.
Participants in that way become used to trying to find reasonable solutions to the problems they have gathered around.
Life in the associations and democracy in everyday life give citizens, in other words, a practical knowledge of democratic values and principles.
The most widespread democratic activity is voting when there is an election.
You are not obliged to vote, but the vast majority do so anyway, and voter turnout, that is how many of those with the right to vote actually vote, is quite high compared with most other countries.
It is particularly high when there are elections to the Folketing, an average of 86 percent since the year 2000.
It is somewhat lower when voting for municipal and regional elections, an average of 72 percent since 2000, and a bit lower still for the European Parliament, an average of 58 percent since 2000.
The generally high turnout in Denmark can have several explanations.
One of them is that Danes are brought up to democracy as children and young people.
They learn democratic values early, and voting is a crucial democratic value.
This happens, among other places, in the folkeskole and in the youth educations.
Another explanation is that the strong tradition of being part of associations strengthens citizens' democratic values and ability to cope in organisations.
Finally, it may also matter that democracy in Denmark has from the beginning been a popular project.
Democracy was carried forward not least by the farmers and the workers.
They were organised early in the great movements that became the parties Venstre and the Social Democrats.
This has created a tradition of democratic participation that still marks Denmark.
Danes today are generally very satisfied with their democracy.
They have trust in the institutions of democracy, state, region and municipality.
But not necessarily in the elected political leaders.
Trust in the politicians goes up and down.
The population's political participation is high compared with many other countries.
But over a longer period, participation has changed character.
Fewer people today are members of a political party, even though anyone can become a member of one if they want.
And the so-called grassroots movements play a smaller role today than they did in the 1970s and 1980s.
Instead, new ways of expressing political views have been created.
It can be by signing a political declaration, a petition, by giving money to a political or humanitarian cause, or by taking political or ethical considerations as a consumer.
Many also take part in political discussions on social media such as X and Facebook on the internet.
Here is your recap for Episode Six.
Sixty years ago voters were loyal to a class party: workers voted Social Democrats, farmers Venstre, the self-employed and middle class the Conservatives.
Today voters switch parties more.
Privately employed vote more centre-right; publicly employed more Social Democrats and the left; men more centre-right, women more left.
Parties are not mentioned in the constitution.
Around 1950 about 650,000 were party members, almost one in four voters; in 2024 about 106,000, about one in forty.
The Social Democrats have about 27,000 members and Venstre about 20,000.
A member of the Folketing is bound only by personal conviction, and may become a løsgænger.
The Speaker is Søren Gade from Venstre.
LO is now FH, and the Agricultural Council is now Landbrug og Fødevarer.
Newspapers freed themselves from parties in the 1960s, became society's watchdog from the 1980s, and the media is called the fourth power of the state.
About 90 percent are members of at least one association, and about 35 percent do voluntary work.
Turnout: Folketing 86 percent, municipal and regional 72 percent, European Parliament 58 percent.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Who does DA represent when collective agreements are negotiated on the Danish labour market?
Option A: The employers.
Option B: The government.
Option C: The employees.
[DA] Hvem repræsenterer DA, når der skal forhandles kollektive overenskomster på det danske arbejds- marked?  A: Arbejdsgiverne  |  B: Regeringen  |  C: Lønmodtagerne
The answer is A: The employers.
It appeared in the June 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Arbejdsgiverne
That's the end of this part.
Well done.